what do you think happened before the
big bang
so this seems this feels like something
that's out of the reach of science
it's out of the reach of present science
because science develops and
as a frontiers advance uh then new
problems come into focus that couldn't
even have been postulated before i mean
if i think of my own career when i was a
student
the evidence for the big bang
was pretty weak whereas now it's
extremely strong but we are now thinking
about the
reason why the universe is the way it is
and all that um so uh i i would put all
these
things we've just mentioned in the
category of speculative science
and i don't see a bifurcation between
that and philosophy
but of course to answer your question um
if we do want to understand the very
early universe then we've got to realize
that
it may involve even more
counterintuitive concepts
than quantum theory does because it's a
condition even further away from
everyday
world than quantum theory is and
remember our lives
our brains
evolved um and haven't changed much
since
our ancestors roamed the african
savannah and looked at the everyday
world um and uh it's rather amazing that
we've been able to make some sense of
the quantum micro world and of the
cosmos but
there may be some things which are
beyond us and certainly as we implied
they're things that we don't yet
understand at all and of course one
concept we might have to jettison
is the idea of three dimensions of space
and time just ticking away
a lot of ideas i mean i think
stephen hawking had an idea that talking
about
what's
what happened before the big bang it's
like asking what happens if you go north
from the north pole you know
it somehow closes off that's just one
idea
um i don't like that idea but that's a
possible one um and uh
and so we just don't know um
what happened at the very beginning of
the big bang
were there many big bangs rather than
one etc
and
those are issues which um
we may be able to
get some
foothold on from some new theory um but
even then um we won't be able to
directly test the theories but i think
um
it's a heritage i think you have to be
able to test every prediction of a
theory let me give you another example
we
take seriously what einstein's theory
says about the inside of black holes
even though we can't observe them
because
that theory has been vindicated in many
other places
in cosmology and black holes
gravitational waves and all those things
um likewise if we had a theory
which um
explains some things about the early
history of our big bang and the present
universe
then we would take seriously
the inference if it predicted many big
bangs not one even though we can't
predict the other ones so the example is
that we can uh take seriously a
prediction
if it's the consequence of a theory that
we believe on other grounds we don't
need to be able to
detect
another big bang in order to take it
seriously it may not be a proof
but it's a good indication that uh
this is the direction where the truth
lies yeah if the theory is gain
confidence in other ways
you